bonjour jean paul chang aux jouets merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous en direct dans
la matinale de rtl france 3 enfants au
lieu de deux on se souvient évidemment
de la politique de l'enfant unique en
chine il ya quelques années c'est
derrière cette politique de l'enfant
unique est bel et bien enterré
oui on peut dire que effectivement même
si on n'a pas supprimé
symboliquement une barrière supérieur
mes trois enfants mais bon ils ont pu
supprimer complètement la barrière une
fois tout cas c'est un signe assez
important d'une politique nataliste
nouvelle et une politique familiale
puisque mon chinois s'attaque à ce
problème était conscient de ce problème
de vieillissement de la population
depuis déjà 10 ans à peu près parce
qu'il ya des discussions à ce sujet à
pékin à l'époque déjà est donc
simplement c'est très difficile de
mettre en place toute une série de
mesures notamment des tirs de de soutien
en termes de relations sociales de
sécurité sociale de retraite ça touche
tellement de domaines et qu' il fallait
y aller progressivement donc il prenait
un moment de l'abandon de la dalle en
forme unique l'appétit venant en sens
unique
visiblement ce n'est pas suffisant on a
supprimé donc même la variable deux
enfants mais il est et ce qui est
important c'est de voir toutes les
mesures d'accompagnement qui risque
d'arriver le problème en de manière très
diversifiés suivant les régions en
province et que nous verrons
probablement des soutiens des cadeaux
nouveau mari et des incitations tout ça
le problème
oui oui vous voyez des mariages
justement la chine qui veut favoriser
les mariages sont les subventionnant un
programme de subvention qui vise je cite
à inciter les citoyens à adopter des
valeurs conjugal et familial correct
qu'est ce que cela veut dire
concrètement alors parce que
effectivement c'est une conséquence de
l'urbanisation qui a été incroyable
moins rapide en chine
est ce que vous savez par exemple que
aujourd'hui la majorité de la population
chinoise vit dans des conditions
dans des villes et des vides qui
poussent comme des champignons et des
villes des mégalopoles cela donc les les
habitudes de vie dans les villes
évidemment font que les jeunes
générations veut profiter davantage de
la vie moderne des loisirs de tout ça
c'est un problème que tous les pays du
monde on compterait l'urbanisation
signifie une natalité en baisse dans les
villes parce que les gens se marient
ouais moi vite plus tard voilà et les
jeunes c'est pareil sans compter
évidemment les conditions les conditions
économiques environnants c'est à dire le
prix de moutier on sait qu'on signe
d'unité coûte cher donc tous les frais
de scolarité pour les enfants les écoles
de l'ebn ses caleçons sont très chers ce
qui fait que les jeunes hésitent à se
marier
c'est clair que il est en recul sans
compter qu'en plus que les conditions de
la paix condition de vie menée dans les
villes provoquent aussi beaucoup de
divorce
comme d'hab on s'est rendu compte qu'ils
avaient aussi et non loin de divorce en
chine et donc il ya tous ces politiques
familiales que la chine essaie de mettre
en place et de manière enfin cohérente
et non pas disons coup par coup
donc on a l'impression que je ne suis
pas étonné à côté du fait que qu'on est
con me suis cogné la barrière du nom de
l'enfant enfin notre camp on relevé à 3
qu'on assiste à d'autres mesures
d'incitation à l'installation du couple
le plus tôt possible dans les huiles et
tout l'émotion qui favorise
éventuellement la pérennité des mariages
est ce que cette baisse de la natalité
s'est accru à cause de la crise
sanitaire ou pas non je crois pas je ne
vois pas je ce que ne suis pas les
informations que j'ai pas l'impression
que le confinement soit et et jouèrent
un rôle quelconque
sa peinture est très longtemps vous avez
marqué en chine que le confinement a
duré beaucoup moins longtemps que que
dans les autres pays et ils sont comme
ils sont sortis la crise qui arrive dans
les autres le problème de ce genre
quand je pense que c'est le fruit d'une
façon générale alors bien le constat qui
a été fait à l'occasion donc
recensement de la population qui les
chiffres ont été publiés récemment qui a
fait prendre conscience et d'une façon
générale sur la baisse de natalité
depuis quelque temps mais ce problème
encore une fois nous verrions chinois
apparemment était conscient de ce
problème depuis pas mal de temps
simplement la menace qu'elles s'apaisent
sur l'avenir bien entendu il sait que
s'il n'y a pas de jeunes pour reprendre
le flambeau de la croissance
il va se poser un problème c'est à dire
les générations âgées ne pouvant plus
compter sur les enfants comme dans le
temps la tradition confucéenne c'est le
jeune génération qui supporte les biens
génération vieillissante et bien à ce
moment là des générations ils sentent
vous tendance à faire de l'épargné de
précaution
à partir du moment où c'est s'ils font
des prédations ça veut dire moins de
consommation moins de consommation ça
veut dire le moins de croissance pour la
chine c'est aussi un problème est
effectivement qu'il y avait des
motivations
c'est moins un problème de productivité
c'est à dire complètes ayant peut-être
moines bras pour travailler comme en
chine quand on pourrait dire mais de ce
côté là je pense que les chinois sont
vise beaucoup plus sur la robotisation
et l'automatisme aussi bien pour
l'industrie le policier à nice mais
s'ils nous problèmes de consommation qui
vous faut à terme le problème de la
présence chinoise et donc il faut alors
vous voyez bien que il faut pour que les
générations âgées ou vieillissantes
dépenses tranquillement bas il faut bien
pas que les enfants qui arrivent et
deuxièmement il faut qu'il ya un système
de retraite en systèmes sécurité sociale
qui soit améliorée c'est pas une mince
affaire de la chine c'est la safer pour
la france n'ont que la l on peut le
changer une question sur il y aurait
plus d'hommes que de femmes
aujourd'hui est ce que c'est une des
conséquences de la politique de l'enfant
unique
bien sûr d'ici là c'était effectivement
la politique de la famille n'est pas ce
que l'on fait
traditionnellement les familles
chinoises assurer la descendance par
l'enfant mal et que quand il ya une
politique de l'enfant unique de manière
très
strictes effectivement il ya une
beaucoup de il ya eu beaucoup d'abandons
de deux enfants enfin de là deux
fillettes qui ont été ont été adoptés à
l'étranger
mais en chine même ça provoque un
déséquilibre et que la commission
masculine est plus importante que la
plitique lequel la population féminine
est ce qui fait que par exemple dans des
régions frontalières comme à côté du
peuple
il ya un emballement de deux mariages
mixtes ou des entremetteurs follonier
vietnamienne passe mal à y arriver avec
des chinois des ménages qui ne font pas
de des pousses possibles localement
merci beaucoup jean paul ii chambre pour
toutes ses explications ce matin en
direct dans la matinale